so we've been requested to do some
experiments in lecture it's a bowl full
of fairy op you've got for that so come
on get to work so now we're going to get
crash Martin and hijack his lecture well
last week I heard that a friend of mine
John salt house who's quite a famous
demonstration lecturer from a
neighboring University in Manchester had
died and so today I decided to dedicate
the last 10 minutes of my undergraduate
lecture to him and John was very famous
for doing demonstration lectures I
invited Pete and Neil to come into my
lecture and to try out some of John's
favorite experiments so that my students
could actually see what he'd done
so what I thought we'd do today is to
show you is one of John's favorite
experiments ok and that's actually to
set fire to some ether in a controlled
way on the bench in front of the
legislature so this is our aretha trough
and this is a small amount of diethyl
ether I'll pour it in here and it'll
slowly roll down there and make a
volatile atmosphere and then hopefully
well see just how flammable is this
compound itself ish so here we go so
there's my ether whoa
so you can see that well a small amount
ether and there was just literally 10
milliliters is enough to track all the
way across the bench and it's actually
still on fire inside this trough and
actually caught fire off from this whoa
there's the gas tap so so John was the
chemist that I'm known for more than 40
years and he had a famous electrical saw
in Lunia sound and light which he
demonstrated all sorts of explosions so
here I have a a torch and this torch
allows me to make a very very nice
mixture of gas and oxygen to burn with a
very very hot flame so I'm just going to
light the fuel which is the the methane
gas from the from the gas tap and well
see if we can light our flame okay so
perhaps if you put the lights off Martin
you can all see that that's a really
quite orange flame it's a bit like the
orange frame with a Bunsen burner it's
not particularly hot it's not
particularly exciting so what I thought
we'd do now is we'd mix in a little bit
of oxygen and see what happens so what
we're doing is opening the tap or the
hole at the bottom of the chimney on a
Bunsen burner and I think you can see
that you get quite a significant ruling
blue flame some of you may have saw neil
was making a bowl full of bubbly liquid
here so I think what we really call is
just to see if we can blow some bubbles
so we're now blowing some bubbles very
slowly because the gas flow is very slow
from the gas when you contain the gas by
some very liquid Oh quite a nice little
reaction so John had a whole series of
experiments most of which I would be too
frightened to demonstrate myself I
showed the students a picture of him
burning a biscuit in liquid oxygen he
dumped the biscuit in liquid oxygen just
like people dunk it in their coffee and
then set fire to it and a flame this
long came out but what was important in
his lecture and was that he didn't just
do the demonstrations but they had some
point to them he was demonstrating a
point how you had to be careful within
flammable solvents or how you had to
make sure that gases if they were
explosive were not tightly contained and
I think the whole chemistry community is
very sad by his death because he did a
huge service to making chemistry more
exciting for everybody not just for
young people and children but also for
old chemists like me